parfois et un peu discernement moi ce
qui me dérange c'est pas qu'elle soit de
gauche de droite c'est qu'elle a tué la
carrière d'un homme je suis désolé mais
pas seulement le plus grave c'est que
par ses excès par ces bourdes par ces
mensonges par ces manipulations elle
détourne des millions de gens de
l'écologie et du féminisme les gens se
disent c'est ça l'écologie c'est ça le
féminisme c'est une aux autres comme ça
et ben je vais voter ailleurs donc elle
est absolument contre-productive donc
même si vous êtes un homme de gauche mon
cher Verdez vous devriez apprécier le
rôle néfaste vous devriez vous révolter
un truc parce que je voudrais remettre
ça je voudrais mettre les les points sur
les i ce soir aussi parce que j'aurais
rappelé sur Éric parce que j'en ai marre
de lire aussi des trucs sur Eric etc
Eric Tolo c'est un homme de gauche non
mais je te le dis non mais il paye son
ami
avec Zemmour on l'a associé à Zemmour
qui n'est pas un homme de gauche
Eric tu as toujours été un homme de
gauche
je le saurai toujours et les autres
c'est rigolo avait des idées racistes
avait des des rollons antisémites
racistes homophobe je peux te dire il
n'aurait jamais fait une émission avec
moi voilà
j'aime beaucoup je ne connais pas ses
idées mais pardon aussi à ce qui est ce
que vous êtes est-ce que vous montrez et
pour les gens je reconnais quand vous
allez au premier rang du Meetic de
Zemmour non mais pardon dans la migraine
mais c'est ce que tu fais tu peux pas
reprocher aux gens après on te voit
soutenir Zemmour et après tu dis je suis
de gauche je vais pas soutenu
non mais une bonne fois pour toute
combien de fois dans la vie il arrive
qu'un de vos copains soient candidats à
la présidence de la République il
m'invite à son meeting je vais au
meeting parce que je m'assois où je veux
mais tu sais personne qui peuvent me
dire où je m'assois ce sont les hôtesses
de l'air et les ouvreuses de guerre
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui j'avais été un soutien de
Zemmour je serai allé à la tribune
j'étais bien
je peux dire
Eric il fait il fait ce qu'il veut y
aller moi je vais te dire je m'entends
je m'entendais très bien avec tous les
candidats reçu ici ouais mais c'est vrai
que voilà il a pas mal aussi avec qui je
m'entends très bien qu'ils m'ont demandé
d'aller dans leur meeting ça voilà moi
je suis pas libre parce que voilà je
parce que je me suis dit et c'est aussi
autre chose on va croire que je soutien
moi je suis allé nulle part voilà mais
est-ce que tu parce que tu as fait
passer ton amitié avant tes idées
politiques c'est ça absolument je
voulais voir ça c'était un événement
très important à l'époque c'était même
un événement qui était présenté comme
même à risque il y avait une tension moi
je voulais être là j'étais là il me
semble que la présence d'un ami au
premier rang oui
je trouve que ça commence pas tout le
temps ça commence avec le comique de
répétition mais juste Éric moi juste un
petit truc parce que j'ai envie comme ça
qu'on mette les choses au clair je te
dis tout on se connaît depuis longtemps
il y a beaucoup des idées d'Éric Zemmour
il y en a beaucoup qui te dérange non
notamment ce qui peut dire sur sur
l'islam et cetera ça ça te dérange mais
personne au monde n'a autant contredit
Éric Zemmour j'ai fait 15 ans équipe
avec Éric Zemmour donc je le
contredisais chaque semaine personne au
monde ne peut se vanter d'un pari bilan
regardez les archives nous sommes en
désaccord sur des tas de points
fondamentaux dont l'Islam évidemment
mais mais pas le seul donc ce procès en
plus ce procès
jamais clos quoi ça recommence à chaque
fois avec les mêmes arguments mais alors
Villepinte et cetera et cetera je
l'animal pas je m'en suis expliqué une
fois 10 fois 100 fois je viens de le
faire une 101e fois je sais que j'aurais
à le faire une 102e fois pour moi c'est
absurde parce que c'est de ta faute mais
c'est pas grave c'est juste qu'il faut
pas encore une fois si tu vas quelque
part tu sais que tu es un homme public
et qu'on va te voir après les gens te
voient est associe tu peux mettre
derrière arrêtez m'associer à ça
Gilles Verdez c'est un ami j'irai jamais
son meeting